on the red carpet at the venice film
festival italian jet setter marina
chiconya is among stars like actress
emma stone
actor michael keaton
and composer alexandre despla who is
jury president at this year's event
chiconia is in her element i mean the
venezuelan festival is my home i grew up
here my grandfather invented this
festival and so it's been all my life
it doesn't evoke anything except the
pleasure of being here again
she first experienced the venice leto as
a child in the company of her
grandfather giuseppe volpi
it was back in the 1930s that the
wealthy politician and businessman
decided to stage a film festival around
the hotel excelsior
he realized that there were a lot of
actors from hollywood that used to come
here on vacation and he would give a
ball and everything and then
he heard about this new
uh success of this media got movies so
he went there
with the pool
where the pool of the excelsior was
they put 50 chairs or something
brought down a screen there and that's
when they started the first film
festival in 1932.
photographs of the festival remind
chiconya of her own youth
for example how she first met the
italian acting legend alberto sordi
he is coming into my cabin and that's me
here
here
that was my boyfriend at the time
soon she was being photographed with the
likes of directors lucino visconti
federico fellini and actor marcelo
mostriani
in 1966 chiconya truly launched her
career as a movie producer the secret of
producing is to find the right material
and the right director and the right
actors and i was friends with them
before
i started producing with them yes i
started producing with them i was
already friends
at the venice film festival marina
chiconya is swept up in a whirlwind of
parties
there are plenty and she's invited to
them all
but they're nothing like the events she
used to put on herself
she recalls one when she celebrated her
golden lion win for producing the 1967
film bel du jour
the whole film world was there from
elizabeth the train fund of our team uh
kathleen gonna the party was for three
directors that i had that were showing
their films here visconti benuel and
mussolini jane was doing barbarella
elizabeth and burton were doing a film
and you know it was just happened at the
time i sent them little small little
eardrums they came and they spent the
weekend on us this came with a boat
she always recorded such moments with
her own camera and has published a book
of her snapshots showing film stars out
of the limelight
audrey hepburn
and yul brynner sunbathing
or elizabeth taylor having her hair done
you've got maria carlos in uh in a
bathing suit showing uh you know showing
off the the boat of anases you've got
the gabo on analysis both you know doing
gymnastics i mean you know just pictures
or people the only thing is my pictures
are not so great
technically but what they have is they
have a life in them and then a natural
spontaneity
fashion designer valentino
and top directors bernardo bertolucci
pierpaolo passonini
and frederico fellini
chiconia's photos offer an authentic
insight into the italian dolce vita of
the 1960s
it was a special fluid of a time well
that's hard to tell you know you have
that's one of the reasons you you know
that's very visual you you have to see
the photographs you have to see the
films that one made at that time you
know um
it was a period when
culture
and beauty
and a lot of wonderful things music all
that were very important
even at the age of 80 marina chiconya
still plays an active role at the venice
film festival
she's still driven by the desire to add
a bit of glamour to the world of cinema
you